most of the time successful modern life
involves lots of technology constantly
being connected with other people
working very hard for as much money as
possible and doing what we're told so it
may come as a surprise that some of the
best advice about modern life comes from
an unemployed writer who lived alone in
the woods and refused to pay his taxes
henry david thoreau reminds us about the
importance of simplicity or authenticity
and downright disobedience he was born
in 1817 in Concord an unassuming town
west of Boston his father was a pencil
maker and his mother took in boarders he
attended Harvard College in 1833 yet he
rejected the ordinary career paths like
law medicine or the church then Thoreau
struck up a remarkable friendship with
the American transcendentalist
philosopher Ralph Waldo Emerson
transcendentalism is a philosophy that
emphasizes the importance of the
spiritual over the material when it
comes to leading a fulfilling life
Emerson and his transcendentalism
had a huge influence on Thoreau moreover
Emerson helped Thoreau find a place
where he could focus on his writing the
older man owned a plot of land in the
woods surrounding the nearby Walden Pond
and in 1845 he allowed Thoreau to build
a small cabin their three by four and a
half meters in his two years in the
cabin Thoreau penned the first draft of
his most notable work walden or life in
the woods which was eventually published
in 1854 it would become an inspirational
text about self-discovery Thoreau argued
that his escape to Walden Pond was not
simply a relaxing retreat to the forest
he settled there to live deep and suck
out the marrow of life as he put it I
went to the woods because I wished to
live deliberately to front only the
essential facts of life and see if I
could not learn what it had to teach and
not when I came to die discover that I
had not lived after some time in the
cabin Thoreau discovered a different
more conscious lifestyle to begin with
he concluded that we actually need very
few things he suggested that we think
about our belongings in terms of how
little we can get by with rather than
how much
can get he managed to sustain himself on
only one day of work a week he pointed
out that walking the distance of a 30
mile train journey took a day but
working to earn the money to pay for the
same journey would take more than a day
like his friend Emerson Thoreau deeply
valued what he called self-reliance he
distrusted society and the progress it
claimed to have made the civilized man
has built a coach he said but has lost
the use of his feet he felt that
economic independence from other people
and from the government was crucial and
while he understood that we need
companionship from time to time he felt
that too often we use other's company to
fill gaps in our inner life that were
afraid to confront the task of learning
to live alone was for Thoreau not so
much about carrying out daily chores as
it was about becoming a good companion
for oneself relying first and foremost
on oneself for friendship intimacy and
moral guidance insist on yourself never
imitate he wrote most of all one should
change oneself before seeking to change
the world Thoreau also viewed technology
as an often unnecessary distraction he
saw the practical benefits of new
inventions but he also warned that these
innovations couldn't address the real
challenges of personal happiness our
inventions are wanted to be pretty toys
which distract our attention from
serious things we are in great haste to
construct a magnetic telegraph from
Maine to Texas but Maine and Texas it
may be have nothing important to
communicate Pharaoh believed we should
instead look to nature which is full of
spiritual significance
he thought of animals forests and
waterfalls as inherently valuable both
for their beauty and their role in the
ecosystem we can best understand
ourselves as a part of nature we should
see ourselves as nature looking into
nature rather than an external force or
the master of nature most of all nature
provides the meaning that money and
technology and other people's opinions
cannot by teaching us to be humble and
more aware by fostering introspection
and self-discovery this mental state and
not money or technology provides real
progress Thoreau optimistically declared
only that day dawns to which we are
awake there is more day to dawn the Sun
is but a morning
perhaps the best testament of the value
of Thoreau's individual contemplation
and personal authenticity is that his
ideas lead him to powerful political
conclusions Thoreau argued that people
are morally obliged to challenge a
government that upholds hypocritical or
flagrantly unfair laws so Thoreau turned
to what he called civil disobedience
peacefully resisting immoral laws and
protest in July 1846 he withheld payment
of his poll tax duty to avoid paying for
the mexican-american war in slavery I
asked for not at once no government but
at once a better government he wrote
after spending the night in jail it was
not until it was picked up by subsequent
reformers that his si civil disobedience
became one of the most influential
pieces of American political philosophy
in history influencing Gandhi Martin
Luther King and the anti-nazi resistance
despite his time as a hermit Thoreau
teaches us how to approach our
frightening Lee vast highly
interconnected and morally troubling
modern society he challenges us to be
authentic not just by avoiding material
life in its distractions but by engaging
with the world and withdrawing our
support for the government when we
believe it's acting unjustly his works
endure and remind us of just how
important it is to remove the
distractions of money technology and
other people's views in order to live
according to our best and truest nature